so just like yesterday today we've got
another TV spot trailer for ant-man and
the wasp just like I thought this is
going to be exactly as it was for
Avengers infinity war as in we're going
to get a new TV spot trailer for ant-man
on the wasp pretty frequently so as long
as they keep dishing them out I'll keep
giving them to you so be sure to
subscribe to my channel to get these
updates on ant-man on the lost as well
as Avengers 4 and all things Marvel here
we go with the trailer the war has begun
and one question remains where is
on July 6 two years under house arrest
you haven't had any contact with Hank or
hope have you
hmm real heroes
and man in the wash teen another not
actual size awesome
if only cap could see you now that man
and the wasp get tickets now so just
like the last TV spot trailer that they
did for ant-man on the wasp this starts
off with clips from Avengers infinity
war and it also starts off by saying the
war has begun which is kind of
interesting because what they're saying
is hey it's not over just because
stano's snapped and wiped out half the
universe it's not over they're gonna
come back in ant-man of the wasp and
Avengers 4 and figure out a way to
reverse this and as I stated in my last
video a bunch of people from Marvel have
already come out and said ant-man on the
wasp is gonna play a big part in what
happens and Avengers 4 it thing goes on
to say and one question remains where is
ant-man a lot of people have wondered
where was ant-man during the events of
infinity war and I think this trailer
has answered our question he was acting
like he was Chewbacca the whole time but
in all seriousness I think that ant-man
of the wasp probably takes place before
the snap happens and at the end maybe
the end credits scene we're gonna see
some people start to disintegrate and
we'll be left with maybe just ant-man
I think the wasp is gonna disappear at
the end but I think dr. Hank Pym will
make it because I think he's gonna play
a pretty important role in Avengers 4 or
perhaps it might happen during the
events of the movie but I think a man
will be inside the quantum realm when it
happened so he won't be affected by it
and it's probably going to be some sort
of combination of both but we'll see in
just a few short weeks the next scene is
actually a new scene and here's a tiny
little Easter Egg for you this agent
that is talking to Scott is actually a
Marvel character this is Jimmy woo in
the comics Jimmy woo has been an FBI
agent he has been an agent of shield
he's been a part of the agents of Atlas
and he's been a part of the g-men not
sure if this is just a tiny little
Easter Egg for the comic book fans
throwing him in there or not sure if
he's going to play a somewhat of a major
character in this movie aunt and the MCU
but it is really cool seeing them throw
him in there as they show what Scott has
been up to while he's been on his 2-year
house arrest agent will asked him if
he's had any contact with hope or
hanck which as you can see here he
obviously has one major thing to note
here is that they do state that he has
been on house arrest for two years which
means that it has been two years since
civil war which is important because the
events of Avengers infinity war have
been confirmed that they've taken place
two years after Civil War as well so
it's highly probable that sometime
during ant-man on the wasp we're going
to see events from infinity war happen
whether that's during the movie or after
the credits and the next and last new
scene that we have in this TV spot
trailer is ant-man suit malfunctioning
now we've kind of seen this in another
trailer but we haven't seen the wasp
seeing him with if only cap could see
now I think from this line and other
trailers that we've seen it's clear that
Scott keeps bragging that he was an
Avenger and that he was on Captain
America's Team and he fought with him
and I think it's gone to his head a
little bit but it's gonna be fun to see
these references and these jokes and
ant-man on the wasp when it comes out in
just a few short weeks so that's it for
this trailer breakdown let me know what
you think in the comments below and as
always hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on ant-man and the wasp
Avengers for Marvel DC and all things
super thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]